it's time for roses and rose a with me
and my notes just fell it's all real hi
so you guys just me again this week why
because it was in New York for work and
then I'm going somewhere else for work
next week and I'm also going somewhere
else tomorrow and so a lot was going on
I'm so busy I supposed to do I'm so
popular it's stuff for work so okay um I
don't have Rosie this week what I do
have is some leftover Sauvignon Blanc
from a really cool winery in Santa
Barbara so you know you got to drink it
because I paid for it pay the extra kind
of speaking of travel
the crew is in Croatia I am so excited
to be here in Croatia Dubrovnik Croatia
if you asked me where the city Dubrovnik
was I would not have said Croatia but
that's where it is and that's what the
Bachelorette is about it's about
learning again we are on season 8
episode six if you've been following
along with us watching Emily Maynard
season of The Bachelorette and the lot
goes down tonight so there in Croatia
and first it's a one-on-one date with
Travis which to be honest was a guy who
I completely was unaware existed except
now I'm making the connection and I
think last week or the week before he
cried in a van so he is the van crier
and apparently he was engaged before
okay and so they go on a one-on-one and
emily is so hilarious
she says that uh during the date Travis
didn't take his shirt off I'm really
bummed out Travis it and take his shirt
off I've been wondering like
[Music]
what's underneath that shirt and she was
kind of bummed cuz she wanted to see
what was going on there that shirt
I appreciate the honest Hambly drink for
Emily's honesty we're gonna get a lot of
it tonight mmm
but Travis goes home by E again honesty
she calls it like she sees it and she
didn't see a future with that guy anyway
then we get more Ryan Ryan is the guy
who told Emily if she gained weight he
wasn't sure if he'd loved her that much
yeah that was a moment that I forget uh
he continued as Ryan says he really
thinks he's got a net there's definitely
an edge to me the mean man comes out on
the football field and he is going to
manipulate the situation but I can jump
into a romantic connection with her way
I could manipulate the situation you
know I can go get the girl I know how to
go get the girl
but guys are on a group date where
they're doing the Highland Games which
I'm pretty sure is a Scottish thing and
weird in Croatia right I'm lost
okay but they're doing it and Chris
cannot throw a log and Arie successfully
throws the law good job Sean breaks the
log
it was impressive Sean looked friggin on
all the boxes again what goes wrong with
Sean I'm kind of trying to rhyme Sean
and wrong what is gonna happen I just
can't figure out why Emily's gonna send
Sean home he seems so perfect and like
perfect for her I mean I know him in
Catherine Lowe are really happy now and
I love them both and I'm glad they're
together and happy I'm just in the
moment of the show to see him saying
what goes wrong with Sean go and Doug's
face when he's tugging on that stick
oh it's because they were plugging the
movie brave at the time that's called
cross-platform
ABC Disney oh and then Chris gets not a
rose but Oh bravery is not washing your
hair and then being okay when it gets in
your own mouth Chris gets a mug for
being brave at the Highland Games
because he sucked the most and Emily
thought he was just trying real hard and
the did is brave to try even when you
are the underdog okay also drink every
time you see a blanket on this show
everyone's cold oh oh oh oh you guys
then I see the famous stone from the
Ahri promo coming I see it I see him and
Emily walking down the pathway with the
stone I know the kids is coming to kiss
we've seen the kiss that I think made
him the kissing bandit the kiss against
the wild kiss there it is he's putting
his hand on her face he's putting her up
against the wall he's kissing her it's
so wonderful
it is so wonderful after our talk
tonight I feel so good I feel confident
again and I feel like I'm back on top of
the world I say this I have never felt
better watching an onscreen kiss a
listers in a movie or reality stars on
network television
then arias kisses they are great
the montage just video of them kissing
yeah we'll see how he kisses the gals
when he is the bachelor right I mean
that's the question because like did he
have extra-special chemistry with Emily
Emily Camus family Mary or Philip II
with anyone back to Ryan Ryan is in a
tight tight Henley and he smells the
date card continuing to make him seem
desirable I'm a guy who's somewhat of a
perfectionist and again he knows how
good-looking and confident he is but
he's also like so humble like what what
do you hear yourself well I look at
myself every day when I wake up and say
to myself who do you want to be today
guess not
oh we had another blanket oh and then
emmeline jefra covered in two blankets
because right Jeff Jeff Jeff see Emily
gives Ryan a lot of crap she says Ryan
always has a line like a line Jeff says
quote you give me the type of people you
give me the type of feeling that like
people write novels about Jeff people
right now was about serial killers so
looking back on this it's surprising to
me that he won I wonder if people felt
this surprised in the moment let me know
if you watch this season then if you
were watching again now I'm getting
really caught up in like the my news of
all this is what we're really here to do
is analyze Ari so Ari is very honest
about what he thinks about Ryan which is
that he doesn't like him Ryan even and
that makes me again
even more so like Ari because hopefully
he'll be that honest as The Bachelor
Ryan then goes on a one-on-one with
Emily and he says the trophy wife thing
again like a trophy wife haha there's
that word again and then she's like
why'd you say that and he kind of tries
to rewrite what a trophy wife means
every man should believe his wife is a
trophy it means like you know every
man's woman should be a trophy I'd say
anything else dude if I mean if that's
really not what you meant be like I put
you on a pedestal or like you know
you're a glorious goddess or like you
rule everything and you call the shots
and like I would worship you because you
know what she deserves to be worshipped
it's not a trophy wife and you don't get
and what that means Ryan can I be honest
with you
okay Emily again calls it like she sees
it because Rorion who's decided cousin
he says he loved to write he loves to
write he's a pro football player a
personal trainer who loves to write and
they should be a great bachelor and Ryan
who thinks he's good at everything and
he writes a long list a 12-point list of
qualities but he wants in a woman and
then also loves to touch my I think
that's important see that one came last
and I come and did it in bold okay I'll
work on it
try to be more magnetic for you Ryan no
Emily says that is why I can't give you
the Rose tonight because Emily does call
the shots and she sends him out and I
have to say that Ryan took it better
than I thought I was expecting a
complete meltdown please let me know
what you thought in the comments did
Ryan size it change your opinion of him
he oh there with another blanket right
now I can't imagine how shocked you know
the guys are you know to find out that I
didn't come back but we built great
friendships and I'll see those guys
again soon
[Music]
my dream bit and then the editing is so
brilliant and they cut to the guys
finding out right is going home and they
heard hearing that he's leaving cheering
I just wish I could see his face that's
shocking man
and then I definitely hope and all of
this is that the way that I am portrayed
is for who I really have you know spent
five minutes with me I'll tell you that
I'm while I've been blessed with many
worldly gifts pray your guys who cut
this up you know do a good job of
betraying zactly who I am and not
an arrogant ass oh then we get a secret
moment just super moment definitely
dollars right re monsoon a great one
we got a secret moment re Goes Down and
just like tells her you know each other
for the ride home if you didn't know
anything like tell you the truth
next week is gonna be fun yeah oh my
getting a rose tomorrow are you ruining
it for me
surprise thank you oh you guys drink
every time there's a major moment with
all right I'm definitely in love with
Emily he says he's in love with Emily I
believe that Ari really cares that Emily
and really is in love with her because
they have had like some really private
moments that don't feel on camera hey
you don't talk to you for a sec you know
what time Emily doesn't know what to do
she flees the rose ceremony to talk to
Chris this is what I use it for is I
love it I don't rules here they do what
you want to do I love 2012 Bachelorette
can we go back and like I was back and I
think I think she's going to just send
them both home because she's so been
calling it like it is and she's gonna be
like look you guys are in it this tear
and all the other guys are in this to
your butt whoa unexpected
Emily the extra rose you asked for thank
you so much are you ready thank you all
right reward the big guys so let's
finish this for Emily and her double
rose giveaway that was unexpected you
guys but I continued like re more and
more please let me know what you think
we are getting closer and closer to
Bachelor have you been looking up
anything online about this season are
you excited are you ready for January
that's what they're calling it the
promos January I love you all so much
and although everyone had a good thing
is giving Christmas is around the core
we're gonna get the best New Year's
present with a new season of bachelor
please make sure to LIKE you can
Facebook subscribe to us on YouTube you
can follow me on social media to talk
about bachelor bachelorette bye
I wish I could kiss my hand the way that
all right kisses another person because
then I could just like good luck to
myself really good love